[Music]
the average person lives 27
375 days that's all we get if we're
lucky
we just wanted to come over and say hi
that first night we were standing in
nature
i am usually very witty and charming
bring it all right
[Music]
this is a horrible idea for a date also
this is a date
no
move in with me i will kick you out if
you suck to live with it
jen your man i know right i would serve
this in my restaurant
come on chop chop chef all right
i didn't know how much i could love
actually love until i met you
i have never wanted anything more than
for you to be my wife
this is all i want on my wedding day
so
hey if we get bad news we should get a
dog
don't say that we're getting good news
he's ours
they found cancer and it spread we don't
have much time left
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we skip all of it the wedding just
feels like a lot right now
we knew that this was gonna be hard i am
in this with you i
can't do this to you you don't get to
choose when i tap out
do i get to choose not alone not anymore
this is gonna be the happiest day of our
lives
[Music]
thank you for showing me what living is
what home is
you make me feel like i could do
anything well he can do anything
it's a one-on-five chance that i don't
see next year four out of five you do
[Music]
every morning i wake up and i choose you
[Music]
i choose us
[Music]
you